ja ich begrüße sie so heute gibt es so
und ich kann das erfreuliche sagen wir
haben fast 800 abonnenten jetzt auf die
lowcost also wer noch nicht abonniert
hat von 1998
wer jetzt noch nicht abonniert hat kann
der 800 punkte von vielen kann es zeigt
wie immer gilt die folien sind finden
sich also direkt ihren unten drin
den kann sie sich als pdf-datei herunter
heute bietet
ein ganz spezielles thema gibt es ein
persönliches liebt dieses thema muss ich
auch sagen nämlich zum thema neuronale
netze oder künstliche neuronale das ist
ja unsere frage bekommt er gleich was
künstlich was virtuell was wirklich ist
diese ganzen kategorien die geraten bin
es verschwimmen wie mir scheint das wird
auch noch eigenes thema sein
virtualität aber heute die künstliche
neuronale netze und ganz zu beginn
möchte sie noch auf ein ganz neues
angebot hinweisen was ich wesentlich den
marcel danke das ist ein neues format
und zwar diesmal wie sie dem der grafik
leicht entnehmen können
geht es hier nicht mehr video sendungen
von 4cast gesamten akustische audio
cinch audio podcast gibt es verdeutlicht
uns hat heute und heute wird die erste
sendung zumindest aufgenommen und ob sie
heute ausgestrahlt wird vielleicht nur
wenn man das schaffen und wir wollen das
so machen dass sie bitte jeweils mit
siegen unter die jeweilige sitzung waren
ihre wünsche auch einschreiben für
themen sendung als wenn sie jetzt sagen
uns wurde hier ein thema zu wenig
behandelt dann schreiben sie bitte den
wunsch einfach in die in youtube
kommentare ein und wir versuchen
möglichst alle wünsche zu nehmen
im rahmen von circa 15 minuten durch
audio akustischen sendungen an den
vorteil dass sie weniger aufwendiges
präsentieren zuzubereiten sind auch
herzustellen sind und dass man sich
besser konzentrieren kann wenn man so
oft am boden als wenn man es mit
mit video also neues format ab heute gut
wie jetzt dann geben wir unseren ersten
like und dann kann es losgehen die
leitfrage dieses seminares als nicht nur
der heutige
des gesamten seminars möchte ich ihnen
noch mal ein bisschen mehr präsentieren
damit dass ganz klar ist wo es geht und
was sie alles erwartet wir haben schon
ein paar sendung gehabt bzw
seminare gehabt als mir geht es in folge
frage wie muss angenommen
philosophischer zugang zu phänomen der
digitalisierung aussehen ganz wichtig
genug für das land weil man kann sich
fragen gibt es überhaupt einen genuin
für diese mission zurück auf das
phänomen der digitalisierung oder sind
hierfür nicht andere wissenschaften
zustimmt zb informatik da gibt es einige
von ihnen darin um sich anzumelden
der informationen zu erteilen glauben
anderen heute über
oder medienwissenschaft oder soziologie
warum sollte jetzt hier die philosophie
was zu sagen das kann man ja mal sich
verhalten wenn man der meinung ist dass
die philosophie cluster zu besuchen hat
er muss man sich überlegen was sie dazu
zu sagen und wie im fokus auch dieses
phänomen erledigt und jetzt möchte ich
eine mögliche antwort geben die session
mehr input von meiner seite
also ich glaube wir können das erreichen
genau in philosophisch über die
digitalisierung zu sprechen wenn wir die
verschiedenen philosophischen
disziplinen auf das phänomen der
digitalisierung anwenden und untersuchen
ob dabei erkenntnisse entstehen und
diese verschiedenen disziplinen sind
folgende ontologie das ist eine genuin
philosophische disziplin und da wäre die
frage liefern haben wir sind zuge der
digitalisierung mit neuen phänomen zu
tun der eine aussagekraft besitzen etwas
ökologisch neu ist macht bemerkte an
sein
neuen prüfungen nichts sicher ist und
nichts strebt auswirkt dann bräuchte man
auch nicht sagen dass man zu tun hat
also man sieht sehr einfach und
technologisch neue identität ins spiel
haben wenn wir es mit causa eingreifen
damit kausalität
das ist also immer so ein hinweis dafür
haben die gründe dafür haben und italien
interessant ein frohes andere soziale
medien oder ein dritter natur nämlich
viel ändern oder heute werden anzunehmen
dass also eine eigene realität eigenen
kräfte neue phänomene die ihnen von den
bisherigen unterschieden sind wie
verhalten sich als sie gegenstände diese
neuen geben den dritten natur der infos
wären zufrieden stellen der ersten natur
dass es unsere biologische natur und der
2 natürlich ist unsere kultur wenn es
sie denn gibt wie fall berichtet das
sind die fragen theologie mit
dann gibt es eine weitere disziplin
piste mogi das ist erkenntnis zu geben
und da kann man sich jetzt
die sierung unsere weise der erkenntnis
der welt und unsere rationalität als
gibt es neue formen der rationalität
besonders zu tragen es knüpft an die
letzte sitzung welche rolle spielt das
finden
der digitalen information das phänomen
der vernetzung von wissen stichwort
informationen also die philosophie der
digitale philosophie als eine app ist
emol ogi der information vertreten
müssen das ist schon mal ganz was hier
mit informationen große rolle spielt und
jetzt kommt entscheidende frage wie
können wir im rahmen der politik ihre
oder digitalität überhaupt noch von der
can gesprächen und wahrheit und falsch
schreibt auseinanderhalten wenn doch
alles was zählt oder vielleicht sogar
etwas existiert oder was wirklich und
das sagt was der florida informationen
ist alles was information l ist ist
wirklich alles was wirklich ist
rationiert
so hatte das new jersey portieren
zugespitzt geben anknüpfen an ein zitat
von jeder sagt er gesagt hat alles was
vernünftig ist und alles was wirklich
vernünftig natürlich bisherige fragen
was ist wirklich gemeint ist hier
wirklich gemein die reale existenz
dieses tool das anfassen kann oder es
mit wirklich gemeint dass im schein ist
das ist von relevanz ist das von
bedeutung ist und dann führt dies aber
schon ein bisschen anders leider kann
man schon sagen informationen ist
prinzipiell etwas was bedeutsamkeit aber
wir müssen kritisch sein das stichwort
fake news informationsflut wie können
wir das wahre vom falschen brands spielt
die unterscheidung von wahrheit
überhaupt zu dem projekt hat also der
kritische punkte und für mich zum
nächsten punkt wurde sowie des geistes
den verpassten sieg unsere gedanken und
mentalen phänomen welt die uns
angekommen sind unserem gehirn und geist
überhaupt extern zieren
als er dies wäre das digitale übertragen
stichworte neuronale hinzu das ist das
thema gehört investition wie können wir
diese struktur externalisierung außen
dringen anwenden als modell können
verwenden
wie verhalten sie neuronale strukturen
des gehirns des geistes also künstlichen
der musiker zwar lässt sich unser geist
zu bauen über ein netzwerk attac
modellieren ist es möglich dass
künstliche intelligenz künstliche
intelligenz ergänzte thema der nächsten
sitzung sein bringen uns in das
künstliche intelligenz klein euro
bargeld sind bewusst sein muss ist
einfach ein phänomen sensibilität als
ein schmerz ist ein bewusstsein
ich kann bewusstsein versperrt zu haben
aber ich kann auch selbstbewusstsein
habe kann ich im einzel bewusstsein auf
mich selbst oder gar willensfreiheit
wurde autonomien besitzt das ist die
frage die den letzten nächsten sätzen
ist so was überhaupt möglich logisch
professionell weg sagt nein
wenn es jedoch nicht realisieren gibt es
das unvollständigkeit ihr leben und so
weiter
goethe und logiker auf dem niveau auf
kurs bringen
und deswegen kann das aus logischen
gründen ich bin das kämpfen ich bin ein
bisschen optimistischer philosophie des
kreis und diätetik inwiefern verändert
und gefährde die digitalisierung des
zusammenlebens welche neuen ethischen
normen müssen im rahmen der
digitalisierung gelten also geld die
alten können wir die alten regeln eins
zu eins übertragen auf das phänomen
digitalisierung ich glaube nicht und
zwar deswegen weil wir hier sind in
einen anderen raum zeitlich logik zu tun
haben wir haben in der anthologie
gegenstände und sind von anderer art als
physikalische gegen bestimmte sind auch
werte werden neu bestimmt was im anderen
wert ist stichwort bitcoin also wie
verhalten sich enormen der dritten
wertung also die vorgaben die
normativität im dritten dann zu den
normen der zweite natur
und dann gibt es noch die ästhetik
liefern eröffnet die digitalisierung
neue formen des künstlichen und
kulturell und trug schon wieder auf neue
form gibt es neue formen damit ist jetzt
wirklich auch gemeint gattungen können
zb interaktive
spiele neue politische gattungen
hervortreten haben wir es hier mit einer
neuen gattung zu tun
ich glaube ja und dann der eigene
sitzung auf diesen ganzen punkten die
ich jetzt präsentieren haben wir eigens
dazu
jetzt mache ich glaube ja tatsächlich
haben die neue gattung gerade hier die
auftritt und welche ästhetische rolle
spielt das finden wenn der e mails juni
version heißt das war oft gesungen wird
das dann wirklich eingebunden wird in
dieses spiel und die ferne schon
verschwimmen der grenzen von fiktion und
realität geht ist natürlich mit einem
schmächtigen stichwort virtualität
virtualität wird häufig der realität
gegenübergestellt sind ein bisschen
skeptisch ich glaube dass diese
unterscheidung zwischen virtualität und
realität gar nicht auf mich acht ist man
auch virtuelle gegenstände wie world of
warcraft oder anderen spielen ein wert
besitzt sie können damit handeln und es
ist für mich ganz klar das zeigt dass
wir es hier und theologie zu tun haben
also wie verschwimmen die grenzen
sächlich verschwimmen und das kostenlos
wenn sie online spiele machen und sich
dann betrieben und das so wichtig für
sie wird das sie in die große geldmenge
im einsatz haben
dann wird es zu einer form unserer
existenz eine neue formen and shine
kommen wir können darüber diskutieren
und jetzt zu guter letzt
kulturphilosophie in briefen eröffnet
die digitalisierung und reform der natur
gibt es so etwas wie eine kultur der
digitalität die sendung hat wenn es
steil der geprägt den hat darauf sind
wir eine der letzten sitzung zu sprechen
kommen ich verlinke dieses hin zum hier
oben wie verändert die digitalisierung
die lebensweltlichen preisen und des
zusammenlebens gibt es einen digitalen
lebenswelt kann man sich fragen um wie
viel
wenn es einen deal von lebenswelt wie
verhalten sich analoge um
inzwischen zu einer kulturellen halten
die hand regeln sie sehen hier spielt
die ethik wieder mit rein aber einfach
kult ums leben
ich glaube tatsächlich dass es enorme
einfach sagen ich glaube dass die
organisierung ersten durch unsere
lebenswelt ganz banal verwendet von
smartphones das permanente verbunden
sein dass dies in dem ein raum der das
erste anzeichen diese ganzen vierte
revolution in der botschaft spricht wir
müssen hier die frage nicht stellen
das wäre ein weiterer punkt
geschichtsphilosophie auf den nutzern
vor ideen vor allem eingehen haben wir
es hier mit einer neuen form von
geschichte zu tun also verändert sich
die lage derzeit gegenüber dem
bisherigen gewesen
das kam jetzt hoffen wir können als es
hier eine inflation von information
immer mehr immer schneller und das raum
zeit nicht mehr so entzogen werden um
die geschichte wie es diese privat
stichwort vernetzung stichwort
lichtgeschwindigkeit überbrückung von
distanzen in wenigen sekunden oder sogar
millisekunden oder noch geringer
das alles spielte verliehen
geschichte einer wollen also ich könnte
hier noch erweitern kommt ein
geschichtsbuch
aber das scheint mir jetzt noch ein
bisschen zu verfrüht zu sein weil ja
wenn es diese revolution gibt sie erst
begonnen habe mit janas florida fordert
sie so winzig dass es scheint
hüte seien hier eine
geschichtsphilosophische sich dazu noch
anmerkungen einfach jetzt fragen sie
scheinen dies ist die methode einsichtig
also wenn wir sofort ist ganz wichtig
dass wir drin auch wenn sie jetzt an
hausarbeiten schreiben dass sie will
mich wissen worüber schweigens sie und
beschreibt das wissen wir wollen hier
den philosophisch hause reisen
und das heißt nicht dass man nicht auch
erkenntnisse der informatik und anteil
wissenschaft und einbeziehen kann nur
man sollte es neben ausgewählten
philosophischer perspektive betrachten
und dass man jetzt ein paar angebote ein
paar leitfragen die sie sich da zur
hilfe nehmen kann so unwirklich
philosophischer sicht weiteres phänomen
zu entwickelt und darauf konzentriere
ich noch ganz kurz in dem kleinen
unterscheidung machen philosophieren
über das digitalen digitale philosophie
gibt es überhaupt zu gast
impulse noch mal geben so ein paar
vorläufer gedanken von mir digitale
philosophieren
ins nennt bedeutet in meinen augen nicht
mehr normal bisschen betont also keine
zukunft spekulation
das machen sie meinen geschmack florida
ein bisschen zu viel anstellen
also ich glaube nicht dass wir in der
lage sind wirkliche aussage zukunft zu
machen
wir sind keine hellseher wir sind kein
handy und marketing strategen zumindest
ich nicht sagen wenn man der zukunft
ausgemacht muss man das begründen
auswärts struktur wie wir sind bisher
vorgefallen war und dann logisch der
abgang auch nicht science fiction
man kann sich alles möglich er denke
auch dass glücklich philosophisch
stichfest ist ist eine andere frage
von trans am post humanismus möchte ich
hier auch nicht betreiben glaube die
conditio humana also die verfassung des
menschen wird sich nicht ändern wäre
natürlich noch eine frage zu stellen
kann
inwiefern verbessert oder verändert sich
die menschlichen radikal ist hier
vertreten natur durch ich meine damit
aber nicht dass der mensch ein neuer
mensch wird es glaubt nicht da bin ich
sehr konservativ aber darüber kann man
natürlich diskutieren
das muss man durch
das halte ich glaube es kann wir müssen
wenn wir nicht wir müssen schauen und
industrie hrung des haben zeit und wie
wir ganze denken also die philosophie
des geistes selbst sich in digital
strukturen wiederfinden und da ist eben
das thema irgend ein bisschen ein
wichtiges zwei differenzen da auch sie
mal ganz zu beginn eingegangen in diesem
semester ich verlinke das wieder hier
oben
analoges digitalen dass die technik und
digitalisierung der digitalität ist die
philosophische seite also reagiert aus
dieser technischen zeit irgendetwas
neues was ich unglaublich wie sonst kaum
seine kräfte dem henker digitalität
hatte schon erklärt dass es so ein
angebot geben diese philosophische
dimension der digitalisierung zu
bezeichnen
kulturelle westlichen richtungen
logische ökologisch ethisch ökologische
und uns eingegangen ein wichtiger punkt
wenn es um die frage nach der mährischen
identität geht als wenn wir uns digitale
gebe stimmen die die dateien anschauen
da informationen sind die numerischen
den tisch sind wir selber an
verschiedenen tischen in ordnung das ist
ein wichtiger aspekt frage dritte natur
gibt es sowas als möchte ich ihnen ein
paar vorschläge machen
warum ich glaube dass es also meine
these dass wir es in der digitalität mit
einem dritter natur zu tun haben die
zweite natur nennt man gemeinhin kultur
und bei der stetigen jedenfalls für die
meisten philosophen und oder so fest
dass die zweite natur und kultur nicht
auf die erste natur die biologische
natur reduziert werden und zwar deswegen
weil er eine spezifische kausale
bedeutung und kraft hat zb ist es ganz
schwer
moralische quote auf die natur zu
genutzt wird
es gibt solche versuche das ganze
gut kam unser zusammenleben und unsere
regeln und gesetze die finden sich schon
rudimentären unserer natürlichen
existenz weil wenn die anderen staaten
schaden wir uns auch und so weiter also
die natur hat in sich schon so eine
gewisse mobilität
aber da bin ich sehr skeptisch glaube
ich nicht schauen sie in der natur geht
es um leben und leben lassen wenn der
wildnis der löwe kümmert sich nicht
darum aber jetzt hier ein kleines reh
frisst er muss über leben und hier
moralische kategorien schon zu bin halte
ich für falsch
jobson kategorie um fehler also die
ganze normativität die moralität keinen
meinen augen nicht auf die hier die
natur reduziert werden das nennt man
sonst auch naturalistischen fehlt es 1 1
und 2 das ist ein anderes thema mache
ich ja auch im linken bein
damals thema sanktionen gegeben verliebt
also ich glaube ich dass das geht und
jetzt kann man sich genauso fragen kann
dann die digitalität wenn es eine dritte
natur ist auf die zweite natur die
kommission reduziert werden
oder gibt es nicht empfehlen das zweite
hat auch erst die natur ihre phänomene
vitalität und spielt dann eine
spezifische qualität und das die
entscheidende frage
wir müssen hier schauen und versuchen
auch das eigene phänomene mit einer
kausalität gibt die sich nicht auf die
kultur reduzieren lassen na prima
fahrzeug könnte man mehr sagen wo die
digitalisierung das ist alles auf unsere
kultur
das ist besonders für veränderte
besonders moderne form und struktur und
es ist halt der liste der kultur
ich glaube nicht dass ich habe dafür ein
paar argumente möchte ich mir vorstellen
wir müssen sie also der dritte natur mit
der natur kontrastieren wie kann das
aussehen ich glaube dass wenn wir die
zweite natur kultur uns mal genau
anschaut stimme festspielen die
legalisierung eine große rolle
inter subjektivität spielt eine große
rolle dass im austausch kommunikation
treten als klar individuelles subjekt
und dass wir niemals vergeben schädlich
und kritisiert als wir wollen das ganze
sozialphilosoph liebten kamera
wir sollen im anderen nicht als
gegenstand ganz wie man ganz anders und
neu wichtige punkte diese erinnerung der
präsentation der geschichte als solche
geschichte wird immer wieder
repräsentiert weil sie droht vergessen
zu werden
das ist auch glaube ich den charakter
riss die komplette zweite natur unsere
kulturen das geschichte immer wieder
angeeignet werden weil einfach der fluss
der zeit sich hier bemerkbar macht
wieder zweiter
genauso auch die räumliche trennung und
die räumliche trennung
sie zeigt wie visualisieren und der
subjektivität dessen beziehung durch
räumliche trennung der herstellung und
jetzt glaube ich dass er mit der dritte
natur in den neuen neue formen gibt und
zwar die vernetzung und das möchte ich
eben kontrastieren inter subjektivität
es scheint etwas anderes zu sein weil
sie die vernetzung ist immer schon da
muss nicht so hergestellt werden wie
wurdest interaktivität trans
subjektivierung wenn etwas dazu sagen
dank damit meine ich das eben
subjektivität immer geteilt ist hinter
objektivierung das stichwort und
räumlich und zeitlich um die adware
sechs ein bisschen genau was ich damit
meine an diese dimension möchte ich
jetzt die im dimension der zeit natur
ist als inter objektivität möchte ich
jetzt prägen als begriff wir können
darüber diskutieren mit glauben und der
objektivität meint dass das alles inter
subjektivität in der dritten natur jetzt
dass wir selbst als einen gegenstand
gegen können der mit anderen dingen also
zb mit kühlschränken oder mit autos als
sonst ein smartphone in einer verbindung
stehen also dass ich dich wurden inhalt
of things also dass die die jetzt selbst
miteinander kommunizieren und wir selbst
auch letztendlich in einem affen
gegenständlichkeit geführt wird was aber
nicht jetzt gleich kenntnissen der
gegenständlichen ihrer kritik des trans
zu kreativität meint dass dann unsere
merkmale der philosophie des geistes
also alles was wir uns gesteckt und
zeitgeist dass dir selbst auf die welt
externalisierung zwar zb durch
also dass unser geist als vorbild für
die welt dient hängt natürlich auch mit
ihnen das mit dem gesang und dann habe
ich noch so ganz an menschen begriffen
müssen darüber diskutieren ob die
nato-mission präsentismus damit
praktisch das ist der ort also die
räumliche distanz spielt keine rolle
mehr wie eine andere logik des raumes
und präsentismus heißt die zeit bekommt
eine andere logik nämlich hier ist alles
präsent und zwar zur selben zeit haben
wir unabhängig von räumlichen distanz
ist alles da und da kann man sagen dass
die welt vergisst sie kennen das rad
unter den arkaden ort dann können sie
von jeder bisher existierende
internetseite selbst wenn es gelöscht
wurde zu beliebigen zeit können sie
wieder herstellen
das ist manchmal ganz lustig wenn man
seine eigenen homepages anschauen und
billig über haben vor 20 jahren für zehn
jahre
wenn man sich anschaut hat erste person
krise unternommen so 1999 sind genauer
zeitlicher
nicht die dann sähe damals darüber
lachen aber wenn ich da was peinliches
drauf geschrieben hätte dann wäre das
jetzt natürlich doch sichtbar und das
könnte ein problem sein
damit will ich sagen dieses gedächtnis
ins kulturelle gedächtnis bekommt eine
neue dimension ist wird schwierig dinge
zu vergessen weil wir alles wieder
ausgraben können und präsent machen kann
und das hat natürlich auch ethische
dimensionen weil überlegen sie mal
stichwort verzeihung und vergessen die
zeit heilt alle wunden finde ich ganz
wichtig aber in der tat problematisch
wenn wir hier alles wieder rauskommen
können und es kein recht auf vergessen
gibt weitere städtische jetzt will man
es gab da mal der affäre mit einer
politikers partie weil da google sich
vorstellt versuch vorschläge gebracht
hat wenn sie bei google einen bestimmten
namen eingeben und dann bisschen mehr
zeichen setzen ein bisschen wagen
stellte google automatisch zu
ergänzungen vor und diese ergänzung
sieht man ziemlich peinlich alle zum
beispiel namen xy verbrechen oder
anklage oder steuerhinterziehung oder
alkoholika und da wurde jetzt gut wie
verklagt
und zwar wurde
gefordert dass bei einer person einen
zug vorschlag ausgenommen sie können
solchen vorschlägen natürlich gut
manipulieren wenn sie ganz häufig einen
bestimmten namen eingeben in verbindung
mit einem kompromittierenden anderen zum
beginn mache dann schlägt es komme
irgendwann vor und es ist peinlich und
das sind natürlich wieder eine frage der
ethik ins weiterbetrieb aber eben auch
wenn ihnen das nicht vergessen und
natürlich der manipulation also diese
drei kategorien glaube ich können wir
reden wie es uns gefällt mir die natur
die dritte turnier noch textur zu
beschreiben dass sie wirklich von der
zweiten land oder kultur verschieden ist
das ist jetzt einfach mal einen
vorschlag von meiner seite bekommen
darauf nochmal zurück in einer der
nächsten sitzungen statt sieben likes
das freut mich wie jetzt richtig und und
jetzt möchte ich noch mal ein bisschen
was hier zu nehmen und zwar thema heute
netzwerke und zwar so sieht es aus wenn
sie mich assoziationen zu diesem bild
was ist damit
genau genau so ein bisschen in der
sixtinischen kapelle gibt es und diese
diese magische berührung von golden ager
unglaublich hier ist es jetzt nicht dass
ich das berührte aber es ist ist es
irgendwie ein übergang jedenfalls und
zwar in zwei sphären einmal lewis
scheint für reportern zu sein und erst
menschen halt wieder inzwischen gibt es
ein netz von knoten von neuronen und
jemand hat es gefunkt hat geblitzt
hier befindet sich man finde ich ein
ganz interessantes bild und der zweig
und zwar haben wir verschiedene
leitfragen die verhalten biologischem
künstliche digitale vernetzung
zueinander das ist ein ganz zentrales
das betrifft jetzt die frage nach ihrer
natur dritter biologie und digitalität
sie geht es extreme ihr spiel die zweite
natur gar keine rolle welche
biochemischen und mentalen eigenschaften
besitzen künstliche neuronale netze wenn
überhaupt systemische fragen können
neuronale netze denken muss man sich
erst mal was ist überhaupt denke das
hängt natürlich das nachfassen unter
denken steht wenn man denken ist er
weiter sehe ja sehr rudimentär ging dann
mit sicherheit liefern können damit ist
er ist übersetzer
das wäre ganz sparen das dann darf ich
verweisen auf dieses video dieser
neurowissenschaftler auch thomas
enzinger dieser philosoph aus mainz der
sagte wenn es möglich wäre dass
neuronale netze oder künstliche
intelligenzen nicht nur
selbstbewusstsein sondern einfach nur
bewusst zeit
dann müssten wir diese neuronalen netze
ethisch besonders behandlung weil dann
könnten wir diesen letzten
schmerzempfinden induzieren auf
beliebige weise und müssten das netz als
ein subjekt ansehen
das geschützt werden meines
leidensfähige ganz spannendes auf all
die fragen können können wir überhaupt
diese kategorie des geistes mitdenken
bewusstsein selbst lust auf solche
objekte betragen das nicht kategorie
gegner sondern auch das werden sich noch
dadurch können
vielleicht ich meine man könnte
ebenfalls sei vielleicht nicht mehr
stützen aber wenn sie eben sehr
emotional und werden sie auf derselben
lebenden menschen anzuziehen auch das
thema freiheit
die sehr selbstbewusst sein müssen wir
von bewusstsein unterschreibt
bewusstsein als nur phänomenales
bewusstsein jetzt schmerzempfinden und
so weiter das bewusstsein
viele tiere haben nur bewusst sein und
schmerz bewusstsein man die tiere haben
auch die meeres selbstbewusstsein wenn
sich spät erkennt man verkehrt erkennen
sie nicht entspiegelt und davon müssen
wir unterscheiden aufsummieren kategorie
also sind gestartet freiheit habe man
die tiere auch und dementieren
wir müssen einfach diese 309 bewusst
sein selbstbewusstsein autonomie der
außenanlagen
sie führen
seine gefasst werden
mit ihren händen
ja der punkt als 100 emotionen empfinden
würde jetzt mit bewusstsein in der eine
verbindung bringen also zb schmerz
empfinden schmerz bisher einen zustand
ist ein mentales verstand zb eine qual
im quali awi ist des clans zu haben ist
ein klarer ich kann meinen schmerz
empfinden eigentlich gar nicht richtig
beschreiben das ist das wie der
fledermaus wie es ist eine feder morgen
ich kann es was sagen kannst du sagen
weder maus nimmt mit bestrahlung oder
schal kulturschalen usw nimmt diese
dinge war aber damit habe ich nichts
darüber gesagt wie es ist eine besondere
zeit sich anfühlt und ich würde jetzt
emotionen psychologische zustimmen
gefühle perfekte alles unter gewissen
zeiten des finden die kategorie des
bewusstseins ist das bewusstsein der
anderen seite
[Musik]
also bewusst sein wer deshalb jetzt mal
noch nieder stufige nieder stufige
musste sagen wäre noch stärker auf die
von außen oder auch von innen kommen
angewiesen lehrer sich analog das wäre
in tendenziell eher analog tendenziell
die frage sagte borgmann bewusstsein
überhaupt mit mittels solche analogen
kategorien erklären kann es ja ganz
kompliziert philosophie sagt wir können
es eigentlich gar nicht reduzieren auf
irgendwelche waffen und neuronalen
vorgänge sind quasi als sind an einer
eigenen art erleuchtung des werden
dokumentiert und selbstbewusstsein und
autoritär stufige phänomenen und
reflexionen mit dem zug
aber jetzt hat sie sich gewöhnt
essen
gesellschaften konstruiert auch weiter
also lächeln ist nicht angeboren
wie funktioniert das eines leeren ja
eigentlich ohne interaktion und rechts
keine rente gehen
darauf komme noch zu sprechen das ruder
punkt also man kann sagen dass gewisse
emotionen oder bewusstseins form
zumindest bei menschen ab der geburt da
sind sogar sprechen dabei innerhalb
zumal so das ist einfach da dass man
zeigen kann
aber emotionen das nicht gleich
emotionen das gehör stufige emotionen
komplexere emotion komplexere
bewusstseinszustände gibt selbst zu
essen und dazu winter subjektivität und
benötigt
das können wir doch behaupten
als wir kommen gleich noch glaube ich
habe jetzt ein paar folien vorbereitet
wo wir genau mal auf die arbeitsweise in
euren herzen schauen dann wollen wir
diese fragen wir jetzt hier an der wand
gebrochen versuchen anzuwenden ist zeigt
jetzt wie sondern alles funktioniert
ganz passanten sieg überleben sich dann
an welchen punkten könnten wir jetzt
solche geilste phänomene anwenden oder
erklärt oder wo können die realisiert
werden nein das machen wir jetzt ganz in
ordnung sagen dass die brust deswegen
spielt biologischen lesen haben wir das
nur irgendwas quasi immer die
roma-politik zum stein aus seinem
geschäft die basis zu bestehen was
eigentlich genau ist aus natur
heraus kommen deswegen spiel ist ein
großes spiel genau also wir können
natürlich auch in diesem moment nicht
reinschauen
wir wissen auch nicht wie es ist ein
normaler mensch zu sein
das ist wie jeder von uns weiß wie es
ist der andere zu sein dass sie kamen
immer nur an zeichnen und sie haben
signale aus als ich auf basis von denen
sie zurück schließen können wie man
sagen ich empfinde schmerz oder jemand
verzieht sein gesicht
dann können sie auf grund für den
vergleich mit ähnlichen zuständen wie es
bei ihm weiter aufschließen
aber sie können natürlich auch irgendwie
zäh fasern phase einziehen
können sie feststellen aber das ist
nicht das hält die schmerzen immer das
quali diese subjektive bewusstsein für
qualität
können sie mir von der anderen person
direkt erleben es gehen und das wesen
das sich das schlüsselbein
deswegen müsse natürlich kritisch
reflektieren wie fern wir solche
bewusstseins mäßigen phänomen in
ansätzen unterstellen können systeme
stange würde es wie auch zwischen jungs
gemalt würden
ihr könnt es läufer gas von bestimmten
zeichen tun oder auf basis einer
bestimmten konstruktion eine
modellierung die so komplex ist das okay
und jetzt gemacht werden künstliche
neuronale netze eingesetzt das wissen
ziehen und zwar überall und zwei
robuster und stift erkenntnissen ein
beispiel ich habe jetzt gerade ein neues
forschungsprojekt möchten texte die so
um 1800 geschrieben wurden gedruckt
wurden und in frakturschrift vorlieben
hier möchte ich zum ersten mal in
lateinischer schrift umland und dann
möchte ich sie über die person können
sie die per dieses neue besetzungs
programm ganz toll möchte ins englische
übersetzen lassen möchte zu wenig arbeit
machen
und es ist ziemlich anspruchsvoll es
vorschlägt ist also texte aus
frakturschrift in lateinischer schrift
als in deutsch und dann von deutsch über
die gns talents englische besetzen
lassen und es geht erstaunlich gut und
es zu speichern jede menge arbeit und
das bekommt dann bei cambridge
university feste haus und die wissen
nicht dass das alles durch künstlich
jetzt eigentlich geregelt wird und
deshalb deutscher sehr gute
spracherkennung bis noch weiterer punkt
heike mustererkennung aber der musste
erkennung von akustisch mal ich hab mir
jetzt daran den lizenzkauf von adobe und
da kostet dann eine seite ein bisschen
was aber das ist auch schon ferien also
be fine reader gibt es aber auch schon
von google werden die kostenlose
erweiterung cr
wer so eine ziemlich gut ist
frühwarnsysteme auch muss der erkennung
und
relation robotik resultat geht es also
auch data mining usw bitcoin auch das
passiert auch wenn ich mich einmal an
den märkten machen zu dieser problematik
die er oft gemacht wird bei künstlicher
intelligenz und autonomes fragen und ich
war dass die unfallgefahr oder so
steigen würde bzw
man nicht weiß wie autos reagieren
würden bei tricky situationen und einem
gedanke der mir immer außen vor
geblieben es bei der diskussion und
jetzt auch dazu passt ist dass wir dabei
wenn alle autos autonom fahren würden
dass die ja nicht eigene neuronale
netzwerke individuell hätten die wir
eigene fahrer hätten die individuell
denken sondern dass alle fahrzeuge an
einer lohnenswerten erzeugt gebunden
sehen
wie finden und das führt glauben auch zu
den begriffen interkonnektivität dass
wir dürfen hier nicht mehr denken dass
wir es in
solide und zu tun haben die das ticket
sind unternehmen erst diesen zustand
herstellen müssen zu amt und dem idol
bestimmten martin heidegger wird das
bestreiten der würde sagen es gibt
kategorien die dimension technik des
seins dann haben einen gewissen immer
schon mal von dem wurden beziehungen
habe ich glaube das ist noch ein
unterschied gibt und tatsächlich kann
man dann bist du interpretiert dass alle
organsysteme wiederum selbst nur
neuronen bekommt den bildern unter einem
großen netz herstellt oder woanders
wieder aufeinander abgestimmt das geld
und das scheint mir auch so eine schwere
brutalität zu sein die sich von unsere
zwei traktoren kategorien unterscheiden
und die wir immer mehr los also ein
künstliches wesen total im trend gerade
war aber nicht immer so in den 50ern
hatte man nicht schon mal wird wenn es
so langsam wirklich untergegangenes
waren zwar aufwändig man hat sich die
rechenleistung und sowas zu den bsv dass
ein schon etwas älterer ein führer der
netze kann ich nicht empfehlen es in der
die haben damals nicht diese technischen
im revier und das direkt alles ein
bisschen leichter integriert aber es
trotzdem ziemlich gut noch debattieren
wie er sagte jede künstliche neuronale
letzten werden geologische kanalnetz
eines informations verarbeiten das
system nach der emigration produkten
da sind wir müssen zunächst die
wesentlichen eigenschaften der
biologischen nervenzellen dem
gesichtspunkt der
informationsverarbeitung studiert und
interpretiert werden stichwort
informationen ersetzen und land
abstrakte neuronale netze sind werden
und durch simulation zu untersuchen auch
wenn die einzelnen geologischen modelle
des gehirns und der verluste von
lebewesen sicherheit herrscht allgemeine
einstellungen darüber dass das lesen der
funktion des nervensystems kontrolle
durch kommunikation nervensystem
bestehen aus vielen tausenden oder
millionen von nervenzellen miteinander
vernetzten jede individuelle mehr
effizient ist sehr komplexen ihren
aufbauen kann ein treffen der signalen
auf vielfältige weise verarbeiten wollen
sind langsam vergleich zur
elektronischen also es ist das letzte
vor dem massiv und hierarchischen
verletzungen des menschen gehirn scheint
die fundamentale voraussetzung für
möglich sein komplexes verhalten
trotzdem haben wir mit lässt
zehn minuten eigenschaften werden
einzeln einzelne neuronen aus der
erzeugung von signalen durch eine drohne
der übertragung auf andere zellen
gehören heute zu den physiologischen
grund gehen wir haben einzelne elemente
komplexe und hof parallele systeme
bilden informationen aufnehmen verein
ist noch weitgehend unbekannt hier
können die mathematik informatik und die
physik ich ergänze und die philosophien
wesentliche beiträge leisten und all
diesen disziplinen werden komplex ist
untersucht es liegt in der natur der
sache dass die beschäftigten letzten ein
rohr grad und ein diszipliniertes
unterfangen zu dem stimme ich zu
ich glaube dass gerade die viel zu viele
mitreden muss mindestens frage inwiefern
hier kommt jetzt eben wichtiger mit
neuen gespielt wenn wir neuronale netze
untersuchen wir versuchen wir
netz also das kann mich auf das einzelne
neumann an
es kommt immer auf der verbindung die
komplexität auf die verletzung und das
nennt häufig auch solis muss alles geben
dass ganz es geht um ein system und die
eigenschaften des systems können nicht
reduziert werden auf den eigenschaften
der einzelnen teile als die das ganze
ist mehr als die summe seiner teile dass
das bestätigte pohlig musterschreiben
wahrscheinlich hier verhinderten und
alles muss ist ein phänomen was wir ganz
zentralen themen dürfen der philosophie
finden vereinbart
hegel aber auch der andere mit
beflockung als sie das ganze ist mehr
als sms erhalten
genau zum beispiel genau als symbolismus
und ergänzt also im erkennt mein weg
bekommen wenn wir eine gewisse
komplexität von elementen mir das spiel
gekommene plötzlich etwas neues eine
kaufkraft oder das thema geben sich
nicht der klärung des über reduktion ist
sich auf basis der eigenschaften der
einzelnen tagen das sind stichwörter wie
hier schon mehr geld sind ganz
schwierige begriff weil so viel gar
nicht erklären kann ist ein wunder
konnten was neues und so leitern und
aber wie es kommt und so dass es nicht
klar
aber das sind stichworte die jedenfalls
den philosophischen natur sind und die
hier auch spielen
das ist noch wichtiger punkt der nicht
zuletzt hinten möchte vorsicht mit den
metaphern und paradigmen wie bei der
untersuchung des nervensystems zugrunde
gelegt werden ist auf jeden fall geboten
erscheint eine konstante und zur
wissenschaftsgeschichte durch sein dass
das gehirn immer an jeweils
kompliziertesten technischen defekt aus
menschlicher hand gemessen wurde im
altertum wurde es mit einer
in der renaissance mit oben und ende des
letzten jahrhunderts
wir müssen sagen des vorletzten platz
sieben zu drei schülerinnen des 19 ein
telefonnetz wirklich vereinigung ist der
computer heute das paradigma wechseln
eines kartensystems ich glaube
tatsächlich dass mit dem werden system
mit am besten dran sind
aber wir sind offen für andere meinung
aller vorsicht bei solchen metaphern
werden wir müssen immer schon im wegen
technologien und mir dann vom leben
einer oder eines netzes natürlich auch
wenn sie mal eine metapher er sagt hier
werden das demontieren des und
informationsverarbeitung des ganzes
stichwort oder es müssen sind es
eindrücke damit signale aus der umwelt
stehe von informationen werden kotiert
und verwertet so dass eine angemessene
reaktion möglich ist geologische
neuronalen eine 54
mögliche lösung für das dort lebt der
informationsverarbeitung ist
unterscheidet sich stark von
herkömmlichen computer als sie mit
massiver parallelität und teils
drastischer baustein und neutralisieren
ist als ich hier gibt es eben neue
verfahren der komplexität
gleichzeitigkeit von haben ja das
verspricht ein bisschen ganze nachlesen
jetzt mittleren reife gehen hier sieht
messen berechenbar gehaltsmodell wie es
gibt ganz verschiedene und elende dem
man künstliche intelligenz man versuchen
kann zu modellieren es gibt diese logik
operationelle möglichkeit mit
theoretisches problem darstellt kennen
sie vielleicht kommt da auf der nächsten
sitzung bis hin zu sprechen
das technologisch reparationen das war
ganz ganz gut imitieren verfahren also
man computer versuchte zu entwickeln
hier gibt's noch lesen können oder
funktionen und das ist nur ein teil
dieses ganzen einheitsmodell selbst die
man noch integriert das sind 41
und so zu einem künstlichen neuronen
modelliert gekommen also es gibt ganz
verschiedene berechenbarkeit zur stelle
und wir greifen wir nur eins raus und
zwar über 17.000 der vielzahl von
möglichen und das ist auch wichtig hier
das ist jetzt die begriffe für
künstliche intelligenz also wir leben ja
heute nicht im weitesten sinne von
künstlich zu begrenzen wir mit der
heutigen sitzung gehen wir nur auf ein
phänomen das sich am besten momentan
regiert aber umzusehen
wir sind jetzt heute hierbei können sie
online sind es nur einen teil wette ein
bereich unter degernau die höheren
fällte der dank an optimierungen ist die
burning man eigentlich nur das wäre es
um noch mit einer zwischenschicht zu tun
haben zwischen ihnen kommt aus dass wir
da noch eine oder mehrere
zwischenschicht namen des nativen also
ganz weit gefasst also gar nichts
spezielles dann wir haben letztens noch
maschinen werden und dann gibt nur die
künstlichen games in europa politik
feldern
unter all diese bereiche und wir
konzentrieren uns heute wirklich noch
diese hellen diesen helden
das ist sonst zu fassen und eines meiner
lieblingsbücher ich halte es für das
momentan beste frau zu diesem thema ist
von tarik unterschied in der übersetzung
von franken langenau neuronale netze
sehr gravierend ein verständlicher ein
spiel mit pfiffen
das ist in meinen augen ist es dieses
buch was dazu gibt hat ganz hervorragend
sensationen bekommen ließ ein bisschen
teuer
ich habe es natürlich digital ich bin
halb fertig waren also jetzt sagt wir
wollen ein neues goldenes zeitalter von
der natur inspiriert dich wurden modelle
optimismus und ambitionen bezug auf
künstliche intelligenz haben 1950 er
jahren ein höhenflug als das thema
formalisiert wurde stichwort pitt und so
1943 lässt der folge zeigen sich neuen
computern in einfache spiele wert und
werden selbst beweisen dass manche waren
davon überzeugt dass innerhalb eines
jahrzehnts maschinen erscheinen würden
wir das niveau menschlichen bereich
tätig doch die künstliche intelligenz
erwies sich als harter brocken und der
fortschritt stagnierte in unseren zehn
jahre stand unter schlechten vorzeichen
invention auf künstliche intelligenz
begleitet von mittelkürzungen und so
begeben
es ist schier so als würden maschinen
und kalter fest verdrahteten die mit
absoluten einzelnen und niemals in der
lage sein die nur außenbereichen
organisch 900 grundstoffen weg prozesse
von jüngeren tieren zu erreichen nach
einer periode ohne wesentliche
fortschritte tauchte eine sehr
vielversprechende idee auf und des
kanadischen lesen aus ihren start zu
befreien
warum versucht man ist schließlich ihre
zu bauen wie man kopiert wie reale
biologische kinder arbeiten reale
gehirne mit nun anstelle von logan
gatter weichere für dynamische
schlussfolgerung anstelle von
kaltenhausen schwarz-weißen
absolutistischen herkömmlichen
algorithmen die wissenschaftler und
inspiriert von der scheinbaren
einfachheit
eines dienen oder 1000 gehirns
verglichen mit den komplexen aufgabe die
sie bewältigen konnten gewinne die nur
auf einen bruchteil die nur einen
bruchteil eines gramms sind offenbar zu
komplizieren aktionen fähig zum beispiel
zu flugsteuerung und anpassungen an den
winzigen spiel fliegen und keine
nationale und beutetiere zu
identifizieren musste erkennen und
schnell zu entscheiden und bekämpft oder
geflüchtet werden müssen als auch muster
erkennen können computer die jetzt über
massive billigeres zosen enthüllten
stichwort was bewegt die siegerinnen
nachbilden und verbessern
eine biene hat etwa 950.000 euro also
ihr können bestimmt weniger als ein
gramm könnten heute die computer mit
speicherkapazitäten und gigabyte und
terracina terabyte bereich die bienen
übertreffen damit den herkömmlichen kann
problemlösung könnte ich diese computer
trotz der massiven speicherkapazitäten
und sogar optionen mehr kernen zu
weitern nicht das erreichen wozu die
relativen sind gehirne von vögeln wie
dieser lage und zwar warum nicht das bis
jetzt eben die frage hier hat man einen
versuch gemacht man es im 18 jahrhundert
was sehen sie hier
ja es ist sehr bitter
genau genau könnte man ein bisschen
erklären gesagt wird also nicht viele
reisende nirgendwo dass unsere seite
verschiedene diäten darstellt in der
lage sein solche schafft genau als titus
manischen kluft als sind wir allerdings
ohne und da drehen in diesem chart
computer setzt einfach ein mann oder
eine person bekannt frau sein
neben rein passt und die daneben
internes die mechanik bedient und dann
wird suggeriert dass das dass die
maschinen liegen zu stützen
stichwort auch perpetuum mobile geht so
ein bisschen diese richtung alte themen
können mechanisch das realisieren
heute stehe ich weiter ginge
das hatten wir auch versucht so was zu
fehlern da war immer immerhin tricks
trinken - jeder im in person also
mannschaft einfach nicht in dieser zeit
auf mechanische weise reagiert solche
kritik kämpfen zu erreichen
das hat nicht geklappt so was sie hier
haben sie mal was ist das hier das ist
es nach gut und wir müssen das personal
noch mal trainieren hat man gewisse
seiner premiere ein bisschen mehr infos
gibt er als sie sehen hier wenn's mal
genau hinschauen
wir sehen hier auch soldaten system hebt
0 15 die patientenzahlen finden sie hier
auflage von diesen planungen könnten
denn diese zahl sieben können sie alles
kandidaten geben und das sind es ganz
klar dass es stimmt erkennung und dazu
sind neben ganz banale neuronale netze
die sich selbst programmieren können wir
den laden und reifen zum beispiel auch
mit hand eingaben sie schreiben was
einst ein kleines feld rainer und es
dann im idealfall wenn sie genug
trainingstag eingespeist haben die
richtige zahl ist zum beispiel so oft
und jetzt dreht den spieß um tauschen
jährigen mit dem computer er sagte davor
computer sind im grunde nichts weiter
als rechner schieben sie können
unglaublich schnell ihren zahlen
bisschen weiter unten zahlen wirken
schnell zu agieren tausende oder sogar
millionen pro sekunde ist sicherlich
eindrucksvoll dort das hat nichts mit
künstlichen intelligenz zu tun
einem menschen erscheint es fiel mir
schwer schnellkurs zu uns will nun doch
ist ihr zu kaufen die wir geld wurde das
interessante
die gäste länger definiert es genügt
vollauf die einfachsten anweisungen zu
folgen
und genau das ist es was die elektronen
computer als erstes agieren solche
grundrechenarten haben sie nur sehr
wenig was intelligenz zu tun
anfangs hatte ich nichts zu tun drehen
wir den spieß um und tauschen mit dem
heimischen computer sehen sie sich die
forscher in versuchen sie zu erkennen
dass hier teilen das ist also eine
gitarre und eine person katze anderen
selbst wir können ein bild mit
menschlichem gesicht sagen eine katze
und anbau 10 brachte steht mit ganze
sehr schnell in der lage und noch dazu
mit einer ziemlich hohen genaues kann
nur in wenigen fällen und liegen wird
die recht großen informationsmengen die
die bilder enthalten können wir sehr
erfolgreich arbeiten und zudem
gelegenheit zu erfassen derartige
aufgaben sind computer verkommen
anfangs war es ist sogar unter auch im
spiel also die information woods aus
zehn millionen 275 1468 und operationen
das mittlere wildflecken scheint für uns
so zu sein dass die erste portion viel
intelligenz benötigt aber okay 494
wenigen und ergänzen
weil hier viel weniger komplexität der
kooperation angelegt ist die wurzeln
ziehen ist können sie in einer operation
immer wieder integriert wird und wie
wollen sie das als informationen angeben
aus diesem pixel eine ein muster ist
eine ganz verschiedene operation und für
uns natürlich viel einfacher weil wir
darauf trainiert sind weil ihr anders
funktionieren aber auch ohne computer
geht ja eigentlich noch weiter wir sehen
sein wird von den kassen haben wir haben
natürlich eine ganze reihe jahres ist
die aktion unser genommen ist zu 74 beim
was heißt nicht versagen und ein gast
hatte sechs geschwister trend milch
etwas neues etwas weiter sonst oder
schauen sie doch mal der kerze ins
gesicht ich finde sie sich ein bisschen
frauen ende ist ja immer so als gehöre
so angaben noch fehlt da ist noch viel
mehr informationen werden wir sagen ja
nicht nur katz wir sagen kannst du mit
bisschen unsicher ist oder vielleicht
kannst du die schönsten so wir haben
dann die emotionen damit auch quasi als
bisher weder kenntnisse damit genau wie
assoziieren das mit an der probleme
dieser baum ist es seltsam wenn wir wie
sie richtig sagen erklärt mit einher
gehen ganz verschiedene weitere
assoziationen ich kann da gar nicht und
es ist so komplex und für uns natürlich
lebensweltlich total normal des brauchen
wir uns überlegt aber von computer ist
sowas
und dann
und soll es geben wir sehen sie doch mal
die übersicht wer kann das besonders
manche arbeiten als problem
tausende bohne zahlstelle x erreicht
könne nicht sein dass menschen
schwertmeister als gewünscht können und
gesicht hat man ein foto mit einem
menschenmenge heraus sowie für den
computer sehr schwer und sehr leicht sie
kennen vielleicht gute captures kennen
sie wenn man also um spam zu vermeiden
so musste erkennen und dann müssen sie
zum beispiel alle fahrräder aus
verschiedenen achtlos aus verschiedenen
bereichen als pilz alle fahrräder hand
und das ist deswegen so extrem schutz
weil es halt wenigstens können trotz
können hat das kam nicht und wir machen
das wirklich wert
ja es wichtig die wahrscheinlichen wort
könnte es schon aber freundlich oder
bräuchte zu schnell wird es zwischen den
marken von etwa hat dessen bruder oder
würde es vielleicht zu schnell macht und
wieder könnte es gar nicht und er würde
es zu schnell machen würde zeit auf eine
weise tun die nicht menschen es stimmt
hier
es muss nicht nur so ein deckblatt sein
dass es nicht einigen als anderes
müssten aber jedenfalls gesichter um ein
foto wie ist es recht schwierig wir
haben das für die mieter gängen menschen
intelligenz erforderlich ist etwas dass
maschinen viele regale komplex und
leistungsfähig wie sie gebaut und weil
es aber keine menschen
doch es sind genau solche probleme die
wir dem computer übertragen möchten dem
computer arbeiten werden nicht müde und
derartige probleme geht es bei der
künstlichen intelligenz der computer
auch elektronik messe steht die aufgaben
der künstlich ins darin neue rezepte
beziehungsweise algorithmen zu finden
hier auf neuartige weise versuchen der
schwierige also für uns leichter euren
computer schwieriger zu lösen
selbst wenn das nicht gelingt dann
immerhin noch gut genug um ein
menschenähnlichen titelkämpfen der
praxis so von jetzt kommen sogar modell
des buches sehr gut dargestellt also wir
bekommen in kürze eingangssignal es gibt
diese arbeiten sollen sie ganz
grundsätzlich informationen
kommunikationsmodell aber ganz ganz nah
sein oder ob er zu was mitte das ist
jetzt schon hier willkommen eingabe die
taschenrechner auftrag dann gibt es
arbeit des prozess oder gibt es die
ausgabe dieses so dass alle und jetzt
jetzt jetzt anders gemacht jetzt weil
sie so arbeiten mit computer inszeniert
von algorithmischen maschinen als wenn
sie den test das ist noch nicht gewiss
ist es nicht ganz zum letzten mal auf
das andere verfahren wir jetzt künftig
in gänze spielt wie die funktioniert und
zu erfolgen lassen
jetzt wollen sie nichts
sie schaue jetzt nicht aktiv auf dem
aufbruch sind sie schaue ich gerne
und das sei noch nicht festgelegt
und so beginnt die uns künste
intelligenz zu haben nicht ins schema
das ausgespuckt wird sondern sie geben
was rein
wir wollen jetzt ausprobiert ob das
verfahren richtig sie achten jetzt auch
diesen mit landkreis zb wollen sie jetzt
kilometer in meinem rechten und jetzt
geben sie einfach mal ein in der mitte
05 also die operation mehrere kilometer
x 5 stimmt natürlich nicht passt
dank vieler von 12 ungefähr 12 01 30
die korrekte mine betragen müsste 62
sein also mit dem faktor 1 905 heißt es
und jetzt müssen sie einfach
ausprobieren jetzt ändern sie den faktor
fünf anders kommt ist es halt das
richtige ergebnis
als ausgangsbasis zustimmen wenn sie
jetzt zum beispiel stärke 9,5 hier rot
ist kreis als 60 61 dann bekommen sie
gerne alles geregelt wäre dann sind sie
ganz nah am korrekten wert dran also
minimal
das wurde passt schon genügend hatte und
so funktioniert ganz passend ist es also
müssen einfach fehlerkorrektur sie
müssen einen passen macht ständig sie
müssen die werte verändern in diesem
operationsbereich und enzian
ausgangsdaten satz der die ergebnisse
richtig an sagt sie müssen so lange
probieren es ein versteck für das
probieren dann durch den menschen soll
analog gestartet in der nacht des 9
es graut es nur unter den letzten mut
machen wenn es komplex genug ist der
braucht jedenfalls ganz großen
datensätzen in dem man das system
füttert das einmal wieder gespeist und
das wäre jetzt einfach hier gerade zu
wenig und aber so gute frage ob sie
glauben oder nicht wir sind gerade die
in prinzipiellen prozessen eine neue
hallen wenn es durch gegangen wir haben
die maschine training hier ist damit sie
immer besser darin wird die richtige
antwort zu geben
es lohnt sich kurz zu halten darüber
nachzudenken wir haben ein problem nicht
nur ein einziger schritt gehen abgelöst
wie wir es oftmals in der schon 19
über wissenschaftliche problemzone
stattdessen haben wir einen gänzlich
anderen weg eingeschlagen den wir auf
die antwort ausprobiert und sie
wiederholt verbessert haben entspricht
auch interaktiv meinen damit dass eine
antwort obwohl spiel für spiel besser im
ernährungs verfahren dessen würde denn
das des universums das wäre eben der
punkt dass es eben schon vorausgesetzt
habe ich mein man könnte aber auch
teilen können auch teilen
wir haben es halt umgetrieben erhalten
haben vertauschten man könnte natürlich
auch mit mit dem addition zu fand sie
wissen ja die ganzen großen kein
integrale überschlagen
grundvoraussetzung swayze am recht der
ist schon eine gewisse voraussetzungen
dieses team ist nicht gänzlich
voraussetzungslos sich aber man würde
natürlich kann so vorgeht dass man immer
einfachsten operation anwendungen
vielleicht sogar gar nicht und
multiplizieren sind agieren oder so man
kann der modifikation in addition noch
auslöst müsst also du bist erst und ganz
einfaches verfahren finden wir kommen
aber gleich auf komplexe verfahren das
ziel leistungs welche menschliche gehirn
termine 14 milliarden euro 100
milliarden kronen
er hat das alles sehr viele eine
fruchtfliege bis jetzt lediglich 100.000
und es damit schon der lage zu fliegen
zu fressen gefahren auszuweichen nahrung
zu suchen viele andere sind komplexe
aufgaben zu erledigen
da die anzahl von hunderttausende ohne
kapazitäts bereich und der kopf
damit könnte man nun darf versuche ein
solches gehirn und nach zurück mein
vater wurde nach nur 302 millionen was
geradezu verschwindend gering ist
verglichen mit den ressourcen heutiger
digital recht doch dieser wolken einige
recht nützliche auflagen der welt mit
den herkömmlichen computer programme von
viel größeren umfang nicht zurechtkämen
das hat man schon mal interessant woran
liegt also das geheimnis warum es im
theologischen dass sie leistungsfähig
wenn man bedenkt dass sie verdächtigten
modernen computern wesentlich langsamer
sind und aus relativ wenigen
verarbeitungs bestehen die vollständige
funktionsweise von gehirnen wie zb des
bewusstseins ist immer noch ein
geheimnis
das weiß man inzwischen genügend über
neue rolle um auf verschiedene arten der
verarbeitung schließen auf dieses zitat
bezwungen
euro
das weiß ich das müssten sie dann aus
in dem text stand davor genau genau in
dem rohr ausstands drin genommen als
einer der ersten vor wobei zeitlichen
differenzen jahren prinzipien immer mit
besserer technik also aufgehoben werden
können hier habe es geht einfach nur mal
dass man diese komplexität simulieren
kann
und dann spielt der prinz sein sollte
man keine brille wenn die prozessor wenn
man mehr parallelen prozessoren hat mehr
kerne sehen wir uns also an während
funktionieren ist übernimmt ein
elektrisches eingangssignal in würde und
gibt ein anderes elektrisches signal aus
dieser der starken die qualifizierungs
und vorhersagen erschienen die
erweiterungen gezeigt haben und die
einen eingang unternehmen das signal auf
bestimmte meisten arbeiten oder post an
signal ausgehen können wir neuronen als
lineare funktionen darstellen wie wir es
zuvor schon getan haben im jahr funktion
weint sie müssen ja nix wählen
das kilometer matrix die richtige mensa
gibt es neben funktionen sie können die
funktion daneben verschiedentlich sie
haben und in den reifen zu aus und sie
gehen wir das hinbekommen wenn man es
ausgespuckt und es muss eben auch eine
solche gnade
verhältnis von kilometern und richtig
darstellen das ist glaube 06 müssten als
ich in der steigung von kanal und also
im jahre wird die frage funktioniert
euro so dürfen jahre funktionen können
den euro im jahr funktionen darstellen
wie es zuvor schon getan hat gute idee
funktioniert auch noch ein biologisches
honig produzieren keine ausgabe nicht
schlichtweg eine einfachere jahre
funktion der eingabe ist also epsilon
wäre die ausgabe gleich nichts mal mit
konstantem sex so funktioniert bei einer
wohnung nicht mehr
das heißt sein ausgabe hat nicht die
form ausgabe gleich kontakte man eingabe
plus vielleicht eine andere kuh so
können wir die funktionen von rund nicht
in europa
und jetzt muss ich noch kurz wagen
erwartungen gelegen habe es kommt
entscheidend punkten nicht sofort
reagieren
also wenn wir da irgendein input geben
beliebig den tod das denn sonst aus kann
sondern stattdessen die eingabe
unterdrücken bis sie ausreichend groß
ist im ein ausgangssignal auszulösen
man kann sich dies als schwellwert
schwellenwert vorstellung der erreicht
sein muss bevor irgend ein
ausgangssignal steht vergleichbar ist
das mit was das wasser läuft erst über
wenn die tasse vollkommen und gefühlter
intuitiv ist das sinnvoll
generell sollen winzige rausch signale
nicht durchlassen
dann ist nur ausdrücklich starke
gewollte signal ausbildung ab 19 20 habe
ihr gleich kommen anschaulich diesen
krankheiten ein ausgangssignal nur
entsteht wenn ihre eingabe ausreichend
angespielt ist um einstellen wird
erscheint stellt sich vor sie hätten so
eine funktion
leider ist es eigentlich sinnlos weil er
ja hier wird die traktoren haben ein
gutes team aber sie können es aber
andere berlin negativen sind mit
potenzial und so weiter sie haben ihr
beliebig kleine impulse bekommen lieber
was ausdenken und überlegen ist immer
mit aufwendig dass wir unser gehirn
wählen jedes noch so kleine halbe arbeit
und wir wären total überfordert
gebrauchen gewisse gatte gewisse
schweren funktionen die ersten
bestellten komplexität von information
überhaupt in gang gesetzt werden und
jetzt kriegst du eine gute grafik und
zwar folgendermaßen es ist back diese
erschwerten funktion soll damit ganz
ganz wasser außen gedrückt wird also es
gibt hier diesem kreis nur bestimmten
bereich des wo markiert abgeben
überhaupt etwas in gang setze der zeige
nicht diesen roma kinder
betrifft ist der ausgang der ausgaben
reaktiven das heißt nur ein viertel nur
ein viertel diese dieser gesamtmenge des
ausgangs relevant wenn jetzt dieser
zeige in diesem viertel des kreises
liegt erst dann passiert
schön dass wir mit dir wahrscheinlich
unterschiedlich sein je nach neigung und
was man da tut und was und es sind die
neuerung auf
gibt es verschiedene gestellt
gute frage
ich bin jetzt auch kein biologe ich weiß
nur von neuronalen als künstlichen
neuronalen netzen dass man hier da komme
darauf ganz verschiedene funktionen
einsetzen auf die kommen noch drauf also
ich würde jetzt mal vermutet dass das da
durchaus auch eine die welt zitiert
geben zu in den neuronen im gehirn das
also hier auch nicht immer dieselben
schwellenwerte im gelben würde ich
vermuten
je nachdem welcher bereich des gehirns
betroffen ist den ich mal dass es nicht
immer derselbe riss werden auch unsinnig
wenzel mit
spenden werden es über dieselben
informationen
man könne gar nichts dann verändern
keine varianz an bin ich weiß nicht
sicher aber ich glaube nicht glauben
nicht und bei den künstlichen neuronalen
netzwerken da ist es ganz klar dass
ganz ohne unsere ganze wenn es jetzt
mehr
schweden werde funktion dieser folge
dass bis zu einer bestimmten der x-achse
bis zum bestimmt kriegs wert zumal das
seit 1 ist die ausgabe 0 und ab dem
bestimmten kommt dann seine stufen ab rx
größer ist als bekomme hier ausgerechnet
ein breites das ist zum beispiel eine
ganz typische schwellenwert und so ist
in bestimmten xl bis zum stück wie
früher bis dahin gibt es die ausgabe
neuer dann tut sich gar nichts
und erst wenn mit ihr diesen einen zweck
haben sich wahre größe des landes
einen einzelnen wolken und es ist so
dass immer mindestens zwei verschiedenen
angeboten ein komisches forderung dass
der größte teil dieser größe das heißt
ein kritisches ton zu treffen sich wenn
sie was anderes vor gut so sie ist
anders und auch seine polizei ausbildung
nicht gehört zusammen wie die spannende
und umgebung sprachen deshalb weniger
spannende zeit
diese höchste wert von 1000 volt ende
und dass sich bei einer boden der zelle
stehen wird und wir haben wieder ein
paar reste eines senioren selben gut
interessant ist es dort wo
offensichtlich erstellen werden die dank
gesagt beim euro sorgen künstler da
netzwerken wird es noch wie mir scheint
kompliziert weil wir jetzt hier eine
andere funktion einsetzen
das ist jetzt so eine ganz einfache
studie funktion stufen funktionen er
sich noch verbessern in den nächsten
abbildung ich gibt es eine sms funktion
die musikfunktion geplanten sie verläuft
sanfter als die abrupte stufen funktion
was die natürlichen und realistischen
natura neun patienten bezahlt und tue
die natur macht keine sprünge der natur
ist alles gewohnte blieb analogen
analogen haben sie keine sprung fox gibt
es ganze als jetzt gesteht eine solche
sanfte s förmige signet funktion werde
forderung für unsere eigene
zu verwenden forscht auf dem gebiet der
kürzen intelligenz nehmen auch anderen
ähnlich aussehen
diese ist aber einfach und tatsächlich
sehr gebräuchlich ist dass wir unsere
gesellschaft befinden die situation hier
gibt es keine sprung mehr erkannt und
keine e commerce und hills alles und das
ist dann auf diese frage wissen da es
eine funktion mit beteiligen im
männer-einer die sind nämlich dann so
aus als diese zum bezogen dargestellt
dass sie dennoch ihre tics haben also
die die funktionen
wenn sie jetzt für xp einsetzen
dann kommt hier 1 1 bis 1 2 1 durch 2905
und zuerst dann auch hier dessen 35 beim
nix leicht auskommt
diese funktion wird deswegen verwendet
bleiben dann verwendet habe es gelesen
wenn man wenn es um wahrscheinlichkeiten
zu verteidigen
diese funktion ist
wahrscheinlichkeit verteilen also je
nach kontext ihres netzes je nach dem
auf was trainieren wollen können ist
eine wahrscheinlichkeit funktionen
einsetzen
da stellen wir mit all diesen eingabe
haben wir kombinieren und sind
diversität und resultieren dass mit dem
eingabe in dieser funktion die der
ausgabe stellt die spiegel die
arbeitsweise von realen euro und wieder
nächste ab und verschob anschauen das
konzert eingaben zusammenzufassen und
dann die schwärzung auf die kombinierte
summe anzug als es so dass jetzt das
entscheiden hätte sich zu entscheiden
wir haben verschiedene eingegeben
informationen die auf diese neuerung das
ist nur rund 1 stunden
diese eingangssignale werden summiert
also nahtlos bsc gewertet werden
passiert und dann wird die celtics als
input faktor in die funktion eingegeben
und dann irgendwas ausgesprochen je
nachdem wie schwer wir führen zurecht 1
funktion einsätze kommt bei derselben
summe wahrscheinlich anders aus als wenn
sie beschwerden und kommt dann wird
dieser aktion wieder ausgespuckt
und so kann man das ein bisschen normal
zuwächse darstellen also dieser
bestreitet kommt weiter und weitere
parameter ins spiel sie an
oder ganze noch gewicht also nicht jede
eingabe ist gleich wichtig sie können
die verschiedenen eingabe noch mit
bestücken
also faktoren faktoren oder und carmen
adressen besagen die erste eingabe ist
doppelt so wichtig die zweite als band
erst im 2 und so weiter
dann kommt werden die somit gebildet
diese gewichtung und damit die summe
werden die funktionen sind erinnern
können aktivierungs und zum eingegeben
und erst in dieser schwere durch die
sonne verschwindet kommt der
hauptmission output gewagt und jetzt
schauen wir noch mal welche funktionen
es gibt also was wir dieses kästchen
dieses wie diese empfehlungsfunktion
einsetzen können da gibt es ganz
verschiedene funktionen bei mir gibt zum
beispiel eine identität also dass das
was wir als nichts einwenden praktischen
auf haus gekommen
sollte seine ursprünge des gratis
das kann man einsetzen wir können hier
auch sowas einsetzen dass diese
schwellenwerte lektionen die wir gesehen
haben die casinos kommissionen tangens
funktionen
also könnte jetzt praktisch dieses
normale nächsten motivieren dass die je
nach funktion die sie einsetzen
bestimmten kontexten angemessen und
informativ aber auch sich selbst geht
auch geht auch genommen sie können das
abkommen
ich hab gelesen da nix kalibrierung dass
das besonders relevantes wenn die zeiten
der rolle spielen können zeitliche
faktoren mit einbezieht
aber es gibt auch diese normale
durchgängige also man könnte sagen wir
verlieren wieder zurück das ganz locker
aber das wäre also eine rückgekoppelt
funktion das gibt es auch aber häufig
gibt es also nicht geben und hier grund
seines texten oder aussehen wird gleich
hier also müssen das vorstellen
sie haben also die inputs sind jetzt
praktisch x1 wichtigsten sind diese
index die probleme dann werden diese
informationen im gewicht tunnel an diese
damit die basketball-wm hinten als
eine zwischenschicht zu tun haben es mit
die planung zu tun
wir können aber auch sich das so
vorstellen dass wir hier vorbei
inzwischen kleiner und
auseinandergesetzt
unendlich viele einer zwischenschicht
anders motiven zu tun
ganz einfach komplexe und sie müssen
sich das so vorstellen dass jetzt hier
überall gewichtung also geht es eingangs
wird
die werden dann auch gewichtet wenn man
die anderen weitergegeben und hier ist
es immer verschiedene funktionen der
applikation für die funktionen oder
schwellenwert funktionen hinzu das wird
ein unglaublich komplex aber mit den
verschiedenen gewichtungen
und damit haben sie ganz verschiedene
faktoren die sie manipulieren können sie
verhindern können um dann am ende das
system so zu trainieren dass das
rauskommt was haben zu dürfen das ganze
nennt sich dann abhängen also es
unglaublich komplex die parameter und
funktionen die sie einsetzen können und
sie müssen es zu modellieren dass die
funktionen einsetzen am besten auf die
möglichkeit passt auf diesen bereich
gehen sie trainieren wollen wenn das
kombinierte signal nicht groß gewinnt
ist unterdrückt die sich moralisch wird
fraktion des aufgabe signal dass die
summe nicht ausreichend groß bewirkt
dass ich meine funktionen dass das
neuronenfeuer das land ist folgendes
wenn nur einer von mehreren gegen groß
ist im übrigen eingehen dass lediglich
ein gewinnbeitrag leisten kann das
bereits genügend damit ersten unfall
darüber hinaus kann dass man aufhören
wenn einige der bühne für sich genommen
ziemlich aber nicht ausreichend großen
in der summe aber ein signal ergeben
dass die schöne übermittelt haben dies
liefert beim ersten eindruck von dem
komplexen gewissens in den zuschauern
gerechnet
die neuen elektrischen signale werden
von den betrieben gesammelt und diese
wirken zusammen um ein stärkeres
elektrische signale zu werden also bei
diesen wirklichen mit der sie bedroht
und starke mit ist um die schwelle zu
befinden feuer lassen euro ein signal
und des taxis zu den terminalen zu
endkunden und es antreten beim nächsten
mal ein weiterzugeben
diese abbildung zeigt wir mehr erinnern
und auf diese weise
so gesehen ist auf jeden fall dass beide
die immer wieder
so sind sondern da die signale für
import und die auch dort wird wieder als
signal an das nächste weitergegeben
als ganz ganz groß dass uns eine ganze
schimmert es zeigt sich dass jedes
möhren die signale von vielen euronen
vor allem aufnehmen und leben so die
ausgangsform an viele arbeiterinnen euro
und weitergibt ist der fall ist es nur
gefördert wenn die schweiz 15 funktion
neben betroffen
um dieses natürliche vorbild künstlich
nur den nachzubilden verwendet man
mehrere schichten verloren jeweils zu
jedem anderen der vorhergehenden und
nach folgen geschichte verbunden gewesen
sagt das ist nochmal dasselbe gibt es
eine eingang steht ein ausgang des
geschädigten von hinten
man verstehe sich die man eben nicht
beachtet weil sie im hintergrund
arbeitet sie sehen eigentlich nur die
eingabe im selben ausgabe in ihrem
system und was dazwischen ist wir haben
inzwischen schichten sehen sie
eigentlich gesteckt und das macht was
die gründe und jetzt möchte ich zum
schluss macht sie vor hinweisen auf
dieses sehr gefreut
zuerst seien oder behandelt dem rhein
berg für kommunale netz programmieren
begreifen und programmiersprache daraus
habe ich jetzt auch noch die letzten
vorher nicht dieses der heutigen sitzung
ein normaler das netz besteht aus einem
mehrschichtigen ansatz von drohnen mit
gewichten verbindungen wie folgt
organisieren 1 geschichte spielen
konträren besteht aus der hohlen die
numerische merken als vektoren darmstadt
jedes input morgen präsentiert anmerken
diese merkmale können zum beispiel die
pixel eines zu klassifizieren bildes
denken sie noch mal diese schrift
erkennungs kästchen wo sie auch niemand
xy wir haben ein oder mehrere
verdächtige geschichten das sind die
zwischen schlichten die dass die pläne
etwas machen kritiker ist für die
weiterverarbeitung der eingabe schicht
zustimmen erst wenn mehr als einmal
verdeckte schicht hat jetzt spricht man
vom tiefen euro
in diesen schichten werden zum beispiel
filter operation auf kriegst haben dass
man zb rauschten herausgekommen dass man
sagt der ausgabe sind zum kleiden wir
machen den schweren wiersch werden wir
der funktion als diese ganz bestimmt
nicht zb eine texterkennung wenn es im
ocr text verfahren waren wo
stellen sie häufig festgestellt dass
qualität nicht perfektes kann sich ganz
viele chance punkte und meine programme
schmeißt dann häufig kommen punkt heraus
was der herr gerecht ist weil es
eigentlich keine zeichen und da müssen
die stellen der funktion angepasst
worden
sie können aber auch mit ocr programm
das selbst trainieren so können da
selbst die zeit saniert und zum schluss
keine ausgabe schichtmodelle
repräsentierte ziel werde das heißt die
gefundenen klassen die kategorie mit
grund- oder katzen zum beispiel beim
qualifikations aufgaben oder clustering
aufgaben oder eine bereits reihenfolge
wahrscheinlichkeit ist aber dass sich
die funktion der auswertungs programm
und so sieht das ganze jetzt aus guter
letzt allerdings orientieren sind kennen
die hallen sind nur bestimmte pixel weiß
schwarz grau usa gibt die lesen
sicherheitsfunktionen der ein
geschichtlich zweiter dem geschichten
dieses unglaublich komplex weil die dann
meistens viel mehr warum hier ein paar
am 7
vier elemente wie können sie 100.000
reinsetzen und dann läuft das ganze in
verwahrung
tendenz wieder reduziert dann haben sie
der ausgaben sei diese komische pixel
ansammlung diesen hund oder die katze
es ist ein praktisch wenn das klappt
wenn sie das so trainiert die parameter
so verändern dass er wohl gegeben
jemand der durch unwahrscheinlichkeiten
diese kategorien aus bekommt dann hat es
geklappt
aus der struktur eines volks den formeln
connected netzes mit zwei verdecken wie
lehrte ein neuronales netz zu fahren
im vorwege abschnitten zuvor angenähert
sind aufgebaut sind doch wie können
diese lernen mit der art der 23
der lehrer vor dem titel learning
besteht darin dass für beliebige netze
an bürger nur eine möglichst genaue
abbildung von gegeben eingabe vektoren
zum beispiel pixel reich folge eines
films aufgegebenen ausgabe lektoren zum
beispiel klassen hundkatzemaus zahlen
und so weiter erreicht diese abbildung
bezahlen also modell die
herausforderungen der stellung eines
modells besteht darin dass die
kontinuierliche anpassung der gewichte
und die korrekte wahl der aktivierendes
funktionen für die jeweilige geschichte
möglichst viele der eingabe beispiele
dadurch kommt klassifiziert und dass
deren werte zb christus aufgabe
ermittelt werden müssen damit das modell
eine aufgabe lösen kann wird
als vektoren der eingabe stunde für den
geschichten kann dieser gewichtung
anhand mathematischer verfahren so lange
korrigiert abweichung der tatsächlichen
und erwartete ergebnis wird auf eine
definierte vielen stand gefallen ist sie
müssen natürlich schauen wenn das vieh
häuften sich die gewichtung der
verschiedenen verbindung und die aktive
nutzung zu verändern dass eine meiner
besten
das geht nur mit der aussetzung meine
tochter darf und sagt die vornherein
schon
vom kopf her absenzen unter der katze
ist also zu müssen waren sich die
kategorien schon zur verfügung stellen
die frage werden auch wirklich hier geht
es letztendlich um die botschaft ist
wichtigen umgestalteten und es kam zu
teils gab es die gleiche mutation
es gibt einen kleinen bub so ungefähr
muss allerdings schauten fast ist und
dieses hat in fellbach vorkommendes an
das datum und die sika geht es
funktionieren also unterlagen die
vorteilskarten anerkannt und die fragen
die sie jetzt erstellt eines
rechtsstaates team gibt es auch eine
urteilskraft die mangel kann die werft
ihren dement würde dass wir noch keine
kategorie von vornherein hat oder sie
findet und das ist wenn du dass das
erkannt dass ist mit kreativität und da
sagte dass die spanne fragen auch die
blöden maschine auf die über
reflektieren der unterführung also den
kategorien finden oder selbst bilden die
sie davor noch nicht gehabt wo sie mich
nur selbst ein kind
der daten geben hier mal aber die
katharinen müssen gegeben sein
[Musik]
ruth buder damit die oder punkt dass man
sagt schau mal ob hier sich durch
gewisse ähnlichkeiten kategorien
auskristallisiert ja das gutachten oder
produzieren also es scheint gleichen
gewitzte aber das ist denn die
entscheidenden kommen realität und die
frage ob die kalkulieren ob es ihm an
tisch bestimmt ist noch mal eine ganz
andere
aber solche muster erkennen kann ich
auch sagen hier gibt es den typ des
christentums um den tisch herum und das
in diesen tipp aber diese kategorie
nochmals zu benennen ist natürlich so
dass wir die heutige sitzung ist
eigentlich recht gut durchgekommen
keine frage
eine frage hätte ich dachte
was genau aber diese neuerungen die die
unserem gehirn verbunden ist die
verbindungen sind vor allem den jungen
jahren noch so erzielt das sind
darsteller aber das wird es nicht bei
der politik donnerstag seien die
verbindungen waren auch noch ändern
das ist es ist eine spannende frage da
zu sein kostet all das ist so ein alter
sind keineswegs schon gratis
anhand dieses beispiels texten seine
aufbauen mehrere schriften eigentlich
genug erkennen kann zb york verstärkt
die kerle wohnen sanieren und andere
schichten die aktion
inzwischen haben
wenn wir mit einer ähnlichen struktur
die sich zusammen gefallen muss
vielleicht einfach muss ich werde in
dieser aktion gemeinsam und an der
stelle war
ihre zustimmung geben und lassen uns
also nicht von dem tagungshotel gibt es
hier
produktivität kommt weil es so dass
wirklich die geschichten erstmal den
schwingungen die aktion bis dahin
wachsen ungefähr dass werden erstmal
kommen alle verschiedenen anfangs und
endpunkte auf dem guten sind miteinander
so dass die alte wohnung ist für jeden
beide unterschiedliche aktionen dass es
sich im auge für den selben tag wird uns
in diesen beiden zusammen ergeben sie
sich an diesen stellen und bis wir uns
konzentrieren verwenden
ja genau ich glaube auch ihre frage
antwortet mit ja oder nein im ernst
diese plastizität haben wird dadurch
dass wir die spannung wieder verändern
könnten die aktivierungs funktion
verändern kann und damit haben wir die
plastizität ist nämlich immer dieselben
wir müssen ständig irgendwo
und schon passt am besten wir können
vielleicht auch sagen wir müssen neue
neuen lehrers mit dem zu nehmen müssen
sie noch komplexer machen und wir können
sagen wir neben händels raus und weil
das grün schon mit diesem komplexität
nimmt das gelassen was wollen wir
erreichen und wie viele parameter mit
geschichten müssen wir investieren und
das hinzubekommen den künstlichen waren
die bundesbehörden zu vergleichen es zb
werbung also das gefühl dass durch das
beim lösungswegen teil überhaupt
bestehen
dabei fällt nicht selbstverständlich
erzählen gärten zu dem o2 und außerdem
für mich nicht mussten sich selbst aus
der gesamten umgebung geht es hat es ist
nur nicht raus starten das groß dass
sich die direktiven arbeitet woche auf
simone mobil material
wenn es kalt ist diese gruppe julius
gerade alles aufgesaugt wird muss man
fragen sich vor der grenze zu sehen sein
inzwischen nichts mehr erreichen
genau dass diese jungen punkten
die deportationen werden aufgeteilt in
verschiedene werte das als sehr sehr
spannend sie sehen wir haben es hier mit
einer reduktion zu tun als gering ist
viel komplexer wir haben sie mit einer
reduktion situation und nach anbieter
und wir haben es mit einer flexibilität
zu tun wir können die insel verändert
und die partei zu bekommen
das heißt heute gewesen ja uns in
anderen kürze mal diaz 38
in der nächsten sitzung der jugend
weiter am thema der künstlichen des
generell zu nutzen also nicht nur bei
unseren politikern zu weit sie von der
neuen arbeit führte der heutige sitzung
noch einmal aufgreifen
inwiefern kann ein solches
das netz als ein ding prozent aufgefasst
werden
machen sie sich das noch mal gedanken
darüber was können denken ist das ziel
tätig hoffentlich tun
zumindest hier in diesem seminar und ob
so was wirklich adäquat den höchsten
berg und alles netz motiviert werden
kann denkt sie von kommunismus
verbindlich und weiterverarbeiter mich
ja das passt dann wünschen noch einen
schönen freitagnachmittag und bis zum
nächsten